ANDERSEN IS NOT A WEAKNEN.
>> Jim: GOOD START FOR BOTH
TEAMS, LOOKS LIKE EVERY LINE HAS
HAD A CHANCE TO GET HAPPENS HER
GOAL BECAUSE THE KINGS DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE CONTROL OF THE
BUCK BUT THER FIRST PERIOD.
HURRICANES UP 1-0 AS LIZ
BY ARVIDSSON BUT IT STOPPED
MOMENTUM FOR THE HURRICANES.
WHAT DOOFF, WON THE
FACE-OFF,NG
TO EXPECT IN TODAY'S GAME?
BACK AND FORTH, RIGHT OFF THE
FACE-OFF AFTER THE CAROLINA RAN
FACE-OFFS.
FACE-OFF AND SCORE A GOAL.
THIS ONEIMS IT
AROUND THERAWN PENALTY THERE.
BUT THE THE
GOAL COUNTING.
INCIDENTAL CONTACT, INSIDE THEO.
>> Nick: YEAH.
POSSESSION IN TH
OFFENSIVE ZONE WITH THE
FORECHECK.
>> Nick: NOW THE LINE.
HIS TRANSITION SPEED AND THEN
THE ABILITY OF
GIVE THE GIFT OF L.A. KINGS
HOCKEY THIS THE RIGHT
WING AND THEY'LL SET THINGS UP.
DeANGELO IS OUT THERE.
HIS RETUR
>> Jim: A SHOT WIDE OF THE
NET.
OR IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN DEFLECTED
THE SECOND PERIOD BEEN A
FORECHECK BY THE HURRICANES.
BUT LOOK
DRIVING WIDE ON SKJEI.
STOPS UP, FEEDS IT
GETS IT BACK.
TIPS IT THAT PASS RIGHT
THERE TO KALIYEV I THINK MADE
THE PLAY.
THEN YOU STAY ON IT, NOT BAC TH
E OF RIGHT THERE, YEP.
AND JUST THAT LITTLE REACH
ALLOWS
KINGS CHANGE UP AS EDLER T FOR
KINGS TODAY.HE PUCK IS
SENT ON THE BENCH.
SIX ATTACKERS OUT, KEMPE
OBVIOUSLY OUT THE